[Musique]
et c'est justement cette exposition sur
le design européen à la commanderie qui
est le coup de coeur culture de la
semaine pourra parler mélanie poquet
bonsoir quand ça on l'a vu on a vu
quelques images de l'exposition mélanie
une quarantaine de pièces de mobilier
sont présentés et oui c'est un saut dans
le temps qui vous attend la commande est
alors pas au 12e siècle qui est la date
de la fondation du sud on va un peu
moins loin plutôt dans les années 60 70
ce sont les plus représentés dans
l'exposition une quarantaine d'oeuvres
qui vous fait découvrir cette époque il
a fallu choisir parmi les trois mille
oeuvres de la collection du musée de la
ville après guerre le mobilier
l'électroménager se caractérise par une
forme de fonctionnalités de rationalité
et à partir des années 60 il ya une
remise en cause de ce nationalisme et là
le le design oriente des voies nouvelles
beaucoup plus pop joyeuse dans son
expression
plastique esthétique avec des formes
très colorés des formes originales qui
remettent un petit peu en question les
moeurs des formes originales c'est le
mot mélanie si oui ceci cause est plus
attiré par le mobilier classique il ya
de quoi être surpris alors on peut y
découvrir des lampes en forme de gélules
de pilules des poubelles qui sont
penchés on peut même s'amuser à deviner
à quoi sert l'objet exposé et son
présente des oeuvres des grands noms du
design européen et or est ce que ça
c'est par exemple un magistrat ti en
france on peut citer alors le plus connu
sans doute philippe starck instar de ses
dix mille créations lui tout seul c'est
quand même les plus grands designers
france est sans doute l'un des plus
grands designers contemporains au monde
alors l'exposition a débuté le samedi 8
septembre elle est à découvrir dans la
chapelle de la commanderie
l'entrée est libre du mercredi au
dimanche de 14h à 18h et ne tardez pas
pour en profiter elle se termine le 30
septembre
merci mélanie